we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be drunk
yeah hey yeah
here we are folks we're back in studio
it's a
balmy summer day in manhattan
what's shakin sloppy jalopy good to see
you dude
you too you got the uh cold up top warm
down below look well you know
you rock a white shirt when it's raining
now you got to throw something over that
[ __ ] i just ran
first first cleaning in 11 years at the
dentist
wow yeah it was like going in an attic
they were pulling out cobwebs and [ __ ]
porn yeah like weird prom dress
flashlight
right right hot wheels track so
how was it was it a nightmare yeah it
sucked it was actually oh so
i went two weeks ago and they had to
schedule a second one because they were
like it was
not they're like it's fine now but it's
like you just gotta come in more than
once every uh 11 years yeah
wow it's crazy that i haven't because
i'm such an anxious mom who's always
like have you flossed and i was like you
were asking the wrong thing
right if you said have you gone to the
dentist i would have been like not in a
decade plus
yeah but you take care of your brush
twice a day and you floss
i don't floss really oh i thought you
floss yeah unless my mom's listening
then i floss every night mother
i assumed all jews flossed really you
guys seem like flossers
larry david's a big floss guy seinfeld's
a floss guy
i'm offended by that by that
generalization i'm offended that you
think i have my [ __ ] together that much
i mean cause i feel now because it's not
nice but it feels like you don't know me
ah yeah i guess good i'm wearing shorts
with a flannel mark
i just assumed i mean you're circumcised
right it wasn't my choice
i was not consulted on that uh decision
i thought jews were flossing
and uh you know you had your money taken
care of
and you went to bar mitzvah and those
two are
true but but the my mom
every day vitamins and flossing she will
remind me but i don't do
i occasionally i'll floss sometimes i'll
get the pickers
you know those are a little more fun i
like a picker it's kind of cinnamony and
you feel like a
cool guy at least you're not like yeah
that's god i hate it i hate flossing my
dad flosses religiously and then he
leaves the floss in the toilet you know
it's just that green
snake i hate it awful you see that is
the pork
shoulder there's the uh the granola and
pork
shoulder yeah my dad is an animal in the
back he's a hairy hairy shoulders he
pisses
he's just hairy too over me when i was a
kid i'd be peeing he would pee
over my shoulder because he was he's a
big big hulking
frenchman that is that's a ballsy move
very open in the
norman household over the shoulder over
the shoulder
yeah some people sword fight he was
knighting me over there
i was getting the uh the duke of
ellington sir golden shower yeah
yeah exactly jesus but yeah flossing
it's a
it's like that hedberg joke he's like
you think when people say it's hard to
quit smoking it's actually harder to
start
flossing that's great so it's a perfect
analogy perfect
perfect and to take a take a hard quit
and hard start is it's a great
technique there dentists are like con
artists so it's like a ponzi
scheme when you go there because i you
know i have a discoloration in my tooth
and like you have to get that taken care
of it's like a nerve trauma or something
it must have been hit or something
could it happen forever ago and i said
all right yeah i'll do it and uh so i do
it and then they're like and then you
might want to come in and make the
others match and i'm like
what is who are you the [ __ ] wolf of
wall street
right yeah it's like the uh it's like
the mechanic like hey your johnson rod
is screwed up you got to come back and
you you don't know anything so you're
like oh i guess like my molar and canine
and
collapser or whatever you're more [ __ ]
up to do it with your health because
you're like a car it's like
it's a it's a material thing it's true
with your health you're like
yeah i mean i guess i have to i don't
know yeah that's true i mean
i i was on my parents dental plan and i
hate it every minute i hate that i've
had braces for six years i have real
teeth trauma yeah i had a gap in my
teeth i had to get it
fixed all that [ __ ] i had to wear a
retainer the tightening the rubber bands
oh yeah but the rubber bands were rough
oh did you have braces i did but i was i
was so young
okay smart smart yeah i was in the prime
of my high school years brutal
so my point is i would go to the dentist
every
six months yeah which is a kid you're
like i'm back at the dentist again
and then they do the flossing and the
cleaning and they got the pick and that
suction thing
cosby's got a whole bit about it uh they
knock you out
they put you to sleep that was though he
ended up using that one later i think
yeah i had the laughing gas uh but
i uh i haven't gone since like when i
moved out to new york
i was like [ __ ] the dentist and now i'm
like i guess i should go oh yeah you
don't realize how good you have it is
i mean i went to a dentist they
literally had to bribe you
they were these dentists they had video
games there what you playing like
pac-man i'm like this is all you don't
want to get called in whoa
i never had that you're playing they're
playing video games they give you a
little like
slime hand you get throw they give you
like they bribe you with toys
you know because they were like more
outside the box yeah
you know some doctors they give you a
lollipop on the way out these guys
they're like we got little here's a
little slime hand so you're like this is
amazing
and it takes your head out of it because
you're like oh the dentist i hate it and
then you're like [ __ ] it it tricks you
they should do that with a dog why
doesn't why doesn't mount sinai hospital
have like a ps5
yeah they're always behind the time get
a ps5 in that waiting room
good point good point that would ease a
lot of kids nerves and
we had the goddamn the block with the
wire thing that you follow remember that
who's that for what am i amish come on
it's awful i i think we
that's what we amazon doesn't pay taxes
you make amazon
send a bunch of ps5s to every hospital
in the country
that way you're having a bad day that
takes your mind off that's brilliant
i love it amazon bezos if you come back
from space
that's the first business he's out of
amazon what
he's done what do you mean he's walking
away what yeah yeah
you didn't hear that no no he's he's
done
he just has enough money he's like
what's the point he's the richest person
yeah
i kind of even after the divorce he's
like top two i think
yeah i respect that because he's got all
the money and he gets a ton of hate
so i would just be like all right i'll
leave i got all my billions
and you guys can bicker i'm gonna i'm
gonna be on jupiter
it's weird bringing his brother yeah and
you see one guy paid like 28 mil or
something to go with him
no some rich guys like yeah i want to go
to space
i mean how long until they're [ __ ] by
the way i mean once you're in space with
no women
and you have everything you gotta [ __ ]
this guy there's prison gay and there's
uh there's ultra rich
space gay
uh us usr
ultra rich wait uh you are ussr
no usp game uspg ultra rich space game
uspg oh man that's so true
wow what the [ __ ] yeah once you're in
space for too long yeah it's like
it's like prison yeah by the way i don't
even know speaking of the future
what do we got i had these uh whitney
cummings introduced me to these
oh wow and me and giannis got [ __ ]
hammered on these
and you don't feel guilty there's not
much of a hangover they taste great
they're actually kind of good for you
but it sounds like it's good for you
well you got cultures and vitamins and
uh it's you know no sugar yep rip that
puppy open
i guess i should have gotten a four pack
i got a sixer
these are six percent alcohol by the way
acai berry
remember when you learn that for the
first time wow that and
uh quinoa those took me about six years
to figure out
this looks it's probiotic that's what
i'm talking about all right
yeah i'm listening june shine for the
folks at home
they actually sent me a free case after
the whitney pod so i'm i'm a fan
ooh this smells good oh yeah juice hey
hey
it's got a kick but probiotic
i like it i had these once
at a interesting some comedy club was it
it was
uh worcester that comedy club in
worcester
oh yeah what's it called again i know
what you're talking about
they have downstairs i didn't love the
one they had but this is
this is pretty good pretty good also
probiotic and antibiotic both good
one of the rare things where they're
both good ooh that's interesting ah
you tweet it
[Laughter]
uh you see what we got in the mail today
no what do you got in the podcast
gotham studios here on 38th street
i'm really enjoying your new podcast
i've been following you separately for
years i'm glad you got together for this
one
you talked about needing to try some new
drinks and possibly building a bar so
i'm hoping this will come in handy it's
over 80 years old so lots
of inappropriate slang of the day cheers
kenny lipkins from seattle oh my
goodness
just cocktails i'm holding it up if
you're wow it's wooden bound
and it's got just old timey cocktails
whoa look at that
wow this one's messed up the uh the rape
against your will that really these are
really out of
dayton holy [ __ ] no this is cool it's
got measure
like look at this this is like old-timey
wow
yeah that is really cool this is just
this would be fun to just have it we're
going to build a bar here i think yeah
so please vote we're going to build this
set
into a bar because this is this is
almost a dental
waiting room at this point so we need
video games
yeah we need a ps5 we want uh send us
anything you gotta you got a paddle
that's like with a swastika on it all
right whatever you got a
bar light a neon light i like the neon
light
yeah hell yeah anything a cigarette
ashtray whatever you get something bar
now we're gonna get a neon swastika no
i mean you can't you can't deny that's
pretty cool
that's a good look look looking symbol
the neo-nazi bar
anything good anything in neon i feel
like is good doesn't that feel like a
gay neo-nazi bar like people that just
they hate others but they also kind of
hate themselves right right exactly
yeah by the way i'm i live in the
village and it's
gay pride month i am getting cat called
like
yeah the world is ending oh yeah yeah
yeah it's i mean you got that that gay
ball right across the street from you
what's the famous one
uh i got i got the duplex that's the big
one
uh duplex is like famous famous joan
rivers lenny bruce all that [ __ ]
yes great lenny brew story yeah joan
rivers did an open mic there
lenny bruce is in the audience so she's
like freaking out he's the guy
she's new she's young she's insecure
bombs
and she like ran out crying they got
they heckled her they booted her or
whatever it was
and then he wrote a note on a napkin
handed it to the bart and said give it
to her and it said uh
he's like you're green but you got you
got it keep going or something and he
said she said it kept her going for 10
years
damn yeah pretty cool that'd be like if
you know bill burr or somebody
huge gave you a whatever cocktail
napkin's so old school too
damn and he didn't hand it to her
herself so there was no awkwardness he
just
he was she says he was the first comic
to have sex appeal
which i agree with because like rickles
and henny youngman and groucho and all
these kind of
you know schlubby guys yeah he had like
a sexiness about him also he was a bad
boy
yes i mean he like didn't play by the
rules he [ __ ] with cops
yes exactly he made fun of religion he
had black friends
he liked jazz like he was in there he
was like a cool guy
cool guy jew from upstate new york yeah
heroin addict they have died so damn
young
yeah i mean that makes you cool too i
know
that's true like you like when you die
at your peak you always have those fame
those pictures of you looking like a
badass with a cigarette in your mouth
yeah like your only pictures right like
if che guevara was old as [ __ ]
that photo wouldn't wouldn't be as
reproduced ah
so true if jesus got old yeah there's no
story
yeah so true yeah bill hicks
another one we didn't see bill hicks
live along long enough to get old
and have a podcast where he [ __ ] he
shits on everyone for selling out and
then he's doing adam and eve
you know yeah exactly yeah a lot of the
old people
some do it great like bob dylan seems
like he's still bob dylan
but yeah a lot of them just kind of
seems like tinier and crankier
yeah which is okay keith richards though
man that guy
pull up a pic of him now if you can that
guy looks
i mean he looks like a like an old
catcher's mitt but yeah
he he did an interview and he was still
smoking he had a he had a scotch
and the hat on but he looks like
an old treasure patch to avon
rodriguez's hand
[ __ ] he's still going i mean he's got
this
he's got the mickey mantle gene i guess
he looks cool well mickey mantle died
yeah that's true mickey mantle he had
mickey mantle had the gene to like
fight through it but he [ __ ] he died
pretty young oh he did i mean
i don't know matt how how how old was
mickey man when he died
wow richard he looks like an old i
remember mickey mantle with that whole
like don't be like me
speech what [ __ ] yeah i mean he was an
alcoholic i mean i didn't know it's
badass in your prime but when you get
older it's
it's rough maybe he's a handsome guy too
oh yeah
he was the guy when i was a kid we'd go
to mickey mantle for my birthday
what's that yeah you used to have a
restaurant ah yeah
that was a thing every every big athlete
had to have a restaurant they got the
michael jordan
restaurant steakhouse magic johnson's
got a michael jordan and everything in
cologne
yeah how old was he when he died 63.
yeah that's
i mean if you're if you're a freak of
nature athlete that ain't good
yeah that's true maybe we should stop
crediting him as the
you know well he played through it that
was a toughness i'm sure it killed him
man i mean
he was he he was always in pain
pretty good movie hbo movie 61 did you
see that billy crystal made it
it's uh thomas jane plays mickey mantle
and uh barry pepper is great as roger
maris
oh man and it's about the home run chase
because you know maris had the breakout
year for the yankees to
hit 61 home runs and beat babe ruth uh
record
at the time of 60 and it's mantle
chasing him too
and it [ __ ] maris up because i think
everyone wanted mickey mantle to
break the record because he was the star
right right but marish just had the
incredible season and
he was kind of like a quiet guy and
mantha was more of like a star in a
showman and
show up hung over as [ __ ] there you go i
mean that's why probably why i didn't
break the record but he's
has he has you know crazy stats if you
look at his numbers he's
okay he was a [ __ ] killer does the
movie show the whole partying and
everything oh yeah
like a part where like you could see his
liver like it's like through his
skin you can see that it's like bulging
whoa he's like [ __ ] yeah
i mean pretty great legacy though like
whenever you know we talk about burke
kreischer or some guy who's
uh obsessed like a just keeps going a
machine
we call it the mickey mantle gene yeah
because he's just a beast and and seven
is just the coolest number because of
mickey mantle i feel like uh-huh like
yankees are like the only jerseys that
are some of the only from the few at
least in baseball where you don't have
the name on the back and i think that's
kind of cool it's kind of like old
school
i like that yeah it's like a team thing
right
when did they go bad you know
everybody's like ah [ __ ] the yankees
they're cocky they buy all their players
but
in the old days the yankees felt very
good to
support i don't know man well back in
the day there was like the brooklyn
dodgers there was the new york yankees
then there's the mets so it's a lot of
new york teams but uh
i don't know when they people started
hating them i feel like
jetery maybe that time well yankees
sucked from like the late 70s to
the early 90s or so they had don
mattingly who was i'm sure we're losing
people with sports
oh sorry buddy i mean yeah we'll wrap
this up pretty quickly
uh but you know then mid-90s they hadn't
won us i feel like in 96 people loved
them
or at least in new york they did yeah
but they're they they're the evil empire
to any other
right city i get it you know like and
then the mets
something's so lovable about the mets
scrappy underdogs
underdog and then they won the the 86
yeah so
that's a coked out team with a coke out
team how cool is that
and they had keith uh whatever fernandez
yeah keith hernandez and strawberry
strawberry and doc gooden i mean judd
apatow made a great 30 for 30 on them
called doc and daryl
and it's like dude yeah they partied
they should both be hall of famers the
amount of drugs they did it's
insane damn yeah good times
yeah it's also crazy doc couldn't when
he was older threw a perfect game for
the yankees
and or maybe it was a no-hitter or a
perfect game i don't remember but he but
it was like his dad was watching from
the hospital and he like caught it just
before he like
saw it till the end and then died isn't
that crazy
the dad died oh wow that was like the
last thing he saw
damn that's wild yeah daryl was a
[ __ ] freak
hmm yeah huge guy there's rumors he
[ __ ] between indians
wow i could see that yeah why not you
know
gets the heart going although i feel
like i would play horribly i'd be like
smoking like ah you guys go i don't care
you're like walking to the bases because
you're so relaxed you just don't care
yeah like what are we doing this for
yeah you do this to get laid so you've
already got laid
you're like ah [ __ ] the game i already
scored
oh i had something when i lost it what i
lost it but it was
this is so interesting to me but really
oh yeah dude the [ __ ] 60s must have
been so cool it is funny that baseball
played these players just like give
their name to everything like jordan
just gave his name to
everything i know i know and they all
did yeah
it's just so quaint you see those kids
in the 60s and the 50s and
they got their glove and they love they
love mattingly and they love all those
guys but you're like
i don't feel like that is is that still
happening yeah okay
for sure it just seems more adorable in
the 50s when you're like mr mister can i
have an autograph there's something
about that and now it's like
kids are like jaded i feel like right
right do you see stuff like players
handing a kid their jersey i think they
still freak out i'm glad that's still a
thing it just feels like sports is
almost
you know you got cte and we're learning
all about this negative [ __ ] then you
hear about like uh
he beats his wife and ray rice and all
this [ __ ] so you're like
i don't know if just felt more the less
we knew the better
exactly i mean it's like uh
you ever see the movie the natural yeah
yeah that's a [ __ ] fun movie fun
movie was that robert redford
yeah yeah yeah classic man classic clad
i think it won best picture
and you know be careful because a woman
will ruin your career
that's the moral of that story white
women
something evil no that was a that was a
good flag man and uh
yeah there's something about knowing
less because these guys got [ __ ] up
babe ruth got [ __ ]
was an animal he was fat but he could
[ __ ] run if you see the clips
that dude could remove really i thought
he had the worst waddle in the business
no he could he could move
although it all looks like those old
footage it all looks like it was all
sped up
yeah yeah you ever see the footage of
jackie robinson stealing home it's like
it's like the fastest thing you've ever
seen you're like how about because film
back then was a little
zippier maybe yeah uh
you ever hear about is it ty cobb who
was the that racist
yeah they said he would try to cleat you
wow he'd slide into you and try to cleat
you
they said his racism was so bad it was
it was bordered on dementia
that's what a book said pull it up there
man dan baldrov a bit about that yes
that's where i got it i looked
i can't remember the punch line but uh
he's like i think the bit
is you know how racist you have to be to
be considered that racist in 1948 oh
whatever
that's killer that is so funny that's
that's
damn yeah i know that's one of those
that was out there and he
he's a big baseball nut so he he grabbed
it
yeah there's something about baseball i
feel like it's just getting killed in
popularity you know
not just that you know what it is they
wouldn't give
the rights to let people put [ __ ] on
youtube or like on social media
so that will kill you mm-hmm i think
they may do it now but it was
years they didn't do that other sports
were doing that yeah you got to do it
you got to go internet
got to go internet it's true like i'm
not a big i like hockey but i'm not a
huge hockey guy but i will watch hockey
fights on youtube till the sun comes up
or like baseball brawls or
triple plays or whatever you know i just
want the highlights
uh and i also like the backstory to me
the backstory stuff is like
the the strawberry and the mickey mantle
i like the guy
to me when i just see a whole team i
check out
i like hearing about when you tell me
i'm watching a knicks game with you and
you're like that guy was a phenom
and phoenix and they grabbed him and it
was a big fight and they had to
draft him over and i'm like oh now i'm
more invested
yeah because you know the people i feel
like that's how you get me and i
remember i watched the ufc fight with
like dave smith and he was just telling
me
backstory to these guys they're not just
just strangers they're like oh i have an
idea of who they are as people
completely completely that's why like
horse racing and dog racing i'm like
it's just animals running i don't get it
this horse was assaulted and uh
2019 he bounced back you're like all
right right
yeah he was molested and they gave him
drive that's what i want
it's a black horse so he had struggles
yeah
but melissa that's why he runs so
quickly he's trying to get away from his
owner
yeah yeah and they have great name
coming down the line is
diddled
this is the first time he came first
[Laughter]
but yeah man i i love i love sports
movies too because they they make you
fall like as a kid the sand lot was
oh i love the same i loved it or like
[ __ ] man how about like
dude slap shot is great we're talking
about
so good paul newman and dark it's
violent as [ __ ] racist jokes the movies
that
those lines must be considered racist
then because i watched it i was like god
damn
don't you feel like if a director or a
screenwriter or somebody came out with a
movie
that i don't know what the word is edgy
or
uh irreverent now i feel like it would
blow up because we've had so little of
that it's just like
nomads land and all this like heavy [ __ ]
that if that came out now it would take
some heat but i think it would have a
huge numbers because if we're just
craving it
for sure like i mean by the way slap
shot i believe was written by a woman
ah does that not matter can we double
check that i think it was
well that's funny when people like this
is offensive women who come with this
offensive like
it's one of you yes yeah i love that i
love that
yes yes it was nancy downs hell yeah
shout out to nancy
well she's born in 45 so she's uh she's
old school
she's old school good for you nance what
else did she make oh that's
it toxic femininity that
she got canceled that was it and she's
from
massachusetts which is also like you
know pretty
balls of the wallop i mean that movie
when the kids just go and the hanson
brothers going they just start beating
the [ __ ] out of everyone they can't no
one knows
when the team can play so they just
fight teams yeah
they beat the [ __ ] out of him and one of
the guys in the bench goes this is a
[ __ ] disgrace
by the way i'm sorry matt now you're on
[ __ ]
full duty here but did you see that
photo it's going around the internet of
this hockey player pro hockey player is
skating and he passes by the glass
with all the fans and these two girls
have a sign that says
hey jeff do you remember we both blew
you in high school
wow and he's like he's like smiling and
laughing it's a it's a great image
wow yeah there's a woman who claims she
blew seven of the phoenix suns
oh and they're and they're in the
western conference finals right now so
she's taking credit for their success
she's like i got good
i gave him a bump yeah there it is tyler
number 19. we sucked your dick in high
school do you remember us
and they're waving it's so fun to see
women
blowing guys and owning it ladies this
is what it's all about look at that
somebody
like they might be hanging on to this a
little too long well of course these are
sad ladies imagine
imagine if they're married the husbands
are like can you stop
can you stop going to games and telling
players you blew them right you're
ruining hockey for me that's like my
favorite thing
they're just on tv they're like she
[ __ ] she blew him that's my favorite
player
i know i'm gonna start doing this at the
ballet like hey sylvia remember i ate
your ass in
grade school or whatever like we've
we've been to them
we have a friend who uh who was going
out with someone and they broke up and
she's
he's a big knicks fan and she started
dating one of the knicks
oh and he was like i can't watch the guy
i can't root for him it's
it's ruining the games for me what a
nightmare that ain't that would kill me
oh god yeah i mean it'd be like if our
if our ex started uh
banging you know some giant comedian or
something or like oh i'm blowing bill
murray now i'm like ah
come on i gotta go see his movies that's
because we make a groundhog day she
blows him everywhere
we find out that she blows him every day
oh god
you know there's something about that
too where it's like by the way if any of
my exes start dating a nick
that's [ __ ] up because they never
watched the game when i was dating
so you can't just you can't just pretend
you're into it now or
i'm having another one of these
kombuchas do it man they go down easy
it's a day it's a day drink man yeah
yeah it's
great just got a just a nice fruity kick
oh yeah i love it i love that i love the
sound of a can opening too
what do you got on a peeve okay i'm this
is a peeve against me
oh i'm calling out myself because i did
i caught myself doing this and i'm not
pleased with myself
turning the gun on yourself i uh i
it's when people thank you before you
did the thing there's almost like a
sense of entitlement
i did it to someone at my agency i just
said hey can you take care of this
thanks oh i went through i i i was doing
it to be polite but i read it and i was
like
oh i don't like that i said thanks
before she said yes i'll do it
interesting i think it's a little rude
and uh and by the way i'm gonna i'm
gonna double
call myself out okay i wrote th x
instead of thanks how busy am i that i
can't write the full thanks double peeve
gonna myself yeah you gonna that was a
little hollywood move there a little bit
uh
hey get on it assistant thanks
yeah she wasn't even an assistant i know
but i'm just saying like that's how they
talk to their assistant
yeah like i'm with you but at least you
said thanks
i said thanks again when she did it okay
that helps
i think you're okay and you caught it
but i get it but but that's a thing it's
a dick move
yeah it's a bit of a dick move there
yeah thanks
can you do this thanks so i used to be a
busboy and uh
our dishwasher was like this curmudgeon
old guy like old guy
cigarette smoke he had that smock on you
know that plastic smock that dishwashers
wear
and one time a guy goes uh he handed him
a rack of glasses he goes
can you uh do this rack of glasses next
uh we're we're kind of
hurting at the bar thanks and he goes i
didn't say yes yet
and the guy was like well just saying
he's like wait shall i say
yes then you say thanks and the guy was
like okay okay he was just like an old
old [ __ ] but uh that never i never
forgot that
yeah i always say thanks after oh it's
yeah
it's way i just don't want to come off
as a dick yeah well texting also
gives you a little there's some blurred
lines there so i think you're okay
yeah but i caught it and i was like i
don't like that i i appreciate it
i called the peeve on myself yes
see look at that internalizing not
enough people internalize
what uh what do you got uh this is a
weird peeve
but it drives me [ __ ] nuts and i hope
i haven't brought this up before but
i had no problem with the drinking
pockets i know i know it's all a blur
but i was talking to a guy over the
weekend
great guy nice guy but he has the phlegm
in the throat and every converse it's
just every sentence has that gurgle
and you go you want to go clear it just
clear the pipes clear the throat
and then we'll start talking about i all
i can focus on is that bubbling up in
the bat you can hear
the bubble ah it drives me crazy i can't
handle it
yeah you expect him to go ugh and then
it just shoots in your face
exactly exactly and we can all hear it
it's back there it's it's rumbling
uh it just changes the whole
conversation i didn't focus on one thing
he said
it's f and i've become a little more
germaphobic in the last couple years
just
but not like i'm like a freak but i'm
just like ah it's just like it's there
something's wrong clearly yeah
right like i'll take a cold ease what
the second i feel
like i just don't want to travel sick
smart smart
even even like meet and greets i'm
shaking and like hey can we just do a
fist bump because i just if i shake
200 250 hands yeah i'm gonna get a cold
can i get a cold yeah so i just tried to
fist bump i feel like it's a little
better wash my hands after i never used
to do that but i'm like
if i get sick two less times a year it's
worth it of course of course
do you well two questions yeah do you
get nervous about
over correcting with the with the purell
and the
coldies and all that purell it's not
really purell as much i'll just use soap
i'll wash my hands
okay okay but yeah the coldies i don't
do it a ton but if i feel something
coming on
the whole thing is it shortens cold so
i'm like let me get ahead of it that's
yeah i just think zinc is good for you
zinc is killer can't beat zinc
yeah uh i am so grateful my mom just
threw me in the dumpster when i was
six and just you never never sick never
wash my hands
uh i never wear condoms no but
you ever try this guy helps me get
through stuff check that out and that's
not even a sponsor that's a free plug
there noon
what's noon it's basically like if i'm
hungover i pop one of those
if i have a long yeah electrolytes and
that one has caffeine so when you're
hungover it
really gets you back into it wow puts it
put it right in the drink it ain't cheap
either those are like
seven bucks each yeah but you get a
bunch of them 10 servings
10 servings yeah that's not that that's
not bad not bad
it's less than a dollar a serving oh
there you go oh this isn't i'm gonna
yeah i i'll do elect i'll do pedialytes
sometimes i'll do
pedialytes good but again you got to get
pedialyte early sometimes i'll wake up
and chug pee like because i'm hungover
and it's not the same
you gotta get you gotta get it uh before
you're hungover
i'm a big believer you gotta do pizza
the night before you got to have
something doughy in your
body soak it up soak it up man yeah
all right so those are the peeves yeah
um clear the throat
i i had a toast i wanna i love a toast
keep some positive energy
i got a weird one please so i'm just the
dentist and
this is mostly a dentist place thing but
it's other places will do it too
sometimes you see it occasionally places
that have
mouthwash in the bathroom um
yeah you just have you have like a
little like a paper
shot cup oh yeah you see sometimes you
see places have that sometimes
a nice restaurant will have such a
classy movie that is very nice yeah
because how often i'm like ah god do you
have any gum i'm on a date or whatever
it is
and you're eating garlicky chinese food
whatever it is so yeah that's good
i ate a lot of garlic i eat a lot of uh
spicy foods i've never been out and been
like my breath
i've always thought i could use a little
bump
you know of course what's it hurt i
think that's a great toast
to the free mouthwash free mouthwash
good call
we don't need the attendant let's not go
crazy we don't need the old black guy
with the towel on his arm and anyway any
race it's it's
it's the presence that's a problem well
i feel like the racial thing makes it
more guilty i'm like oh
i gotta tip this guy he's got a bunch of
loose mints
you know and i got a family but
uh i just feel like we don't need the
attendant
it's a forced weird forced gig i
remember there was a guy the seller who
used to always be like
nix i'd be like yeah and i used to have
a show on their network he'd be like get
me a
get me a porzingis jersey he was like
and i was like i don't get [ __ ] for free
yeah like this guy wants me to just buy
him like 120 dollar jersey
right right i was like i don't get it
for free he's like yeah right you have a
show on their network
like i don't get it i don't get it for
free yeah like can i take a dump
i'm just trying to [ __ ] now i got to get
you gifts there was a
remember the comedy club comics and the
meat packing oh my god it was like the
best
great club but it was a little
hoity-toity because it was in this rich
area so they had a bathroom attendant
and that was like my home club i was
there
four times a week so i knew the bathroom
lieutenant this nigerian guy great guy
but i would come out of the bathroom and
he'd be like whoa that was a big
[ __ ] i'm like all right what are you
doing kenny
you're killing me so now i gotta give
him a fiver just like hey keep that on
the raps
they can't say that i know we were close
though and he was like he's like i'm at
a comedy club it's part of it you know
he was trying to be funny and
it was that's [ __ ] hilarious that's
like a personal that should be like a
sanctuary that's a personal space
yeah you should not be getting ball
busted in the bathroom that's
i don't care for that i'm going to say
right now on record not didn't love it
i remember i was in a times square we
used to go see movies in times square
all the time after school and uh because
we could double up in those big theaters
too and i just i don't know what i ate
but it wasn't good and it was like
it was like a liquid dump in the
bathroom and i hear
a father and son right outside just
hearing me
do this and the dad to his son goes that
boy has got the [ __ ]
and they both laughed their ass off and
it was like that was a pretty low point
of my life
just having them like laugh and mock my
[ __ ] well i'm just stuck in pain
it's the most vulnerable moment of your
life yeah yeah uh i got one of those
yeah comedy works in denver
i was hungover out of my mind because
you know you party in denver it's a
great town
great town i was opening for schumer
this is how long she was headlining the
comedy works a comedy club
and pete holmes was doing a college in
town so he dropped in so he did a guest
set
back in that day i don't i don't know
what pete holmes is doing now you know
peter from crashing
he was like lights out murderer comedian
he was so good i'm not saying he's not
anymore i'm just saying
i don't see him around i see him all the
time in new york
murder to guess that he probably did six
minutes and it was like
like they were going nuts they were on
there and that club is hot too and that
club is the hottest club
and i was hungover so now i'm watching
him murder and i got in my head and the
anxiety and the sweat and all that
and i had like a set i did okay i got
through it but it wasn't great and then
schumer was
you know schumer so she [ __ ]
annihilated but at one point
she's kind of like 30 minutes in and i
had to have the hangover [ __ ]
i'm sweating i'm [ __ ] blood i'm trip
my legs are trembling and i'm [ __ ]
in the stall
of the comedy club the public bathroom
and these guys come in they're peeing
they wash their hands they're like
man how about that tall guy huh pete
whatever he was [ __ ] amazing
and then the other guy's like i know and
schumer is murdering and he goes what do
you think about the the guy in the
middle he goes
not great and i was like ah i'm in the
stalls
[ __ ] my pants around my ankles i'm
[ __ ] water i'm hungover and i could
hear it was it was soul crushing
that's that's another reason to hate the
non-green room toilet
yeah yeah it's happened to me many times
i remember i bombed
a gig i was working with al lubel many
many yeah
wow lubell great comics give him a give
him a goog
oh man check his letterman's out there's
he's so funny
so i'm such a sweetheart of a guy but an
interesting mind
yeah we're working together uh and
i had a kind of a rough one opening for
him and he did a great job
and i did not so i it was the exact
exact same thing i'm in the bathroom
toilet hear the people saying man that
opener was rough and
uh i'm just in there like you know
listening to it and the part of me is
like do i wait for them to go
you know do i have to just am i hostage
now in the [ __ ] stall i have to wait
for these people to stop they were just
like yeah not funny
i was like you know what [ __ ] i'm a man
i'm going out i went out and they saw me
and they go
sorry it was almost worse that they saw
me they're like yeah it's like they
forgot i was a human being
right right yes you have feelings which
is what the internet is that's what
comments are you're like oh these people
have feelings
they don't know that yeah damn you got a
comment section
in real time in real time and they just
they hit me with the sorry i was like
what could he do
i like that you're like i'm a man i'm
going out there like no no
be a man and keep your dignity stay in
the stay in the stall i say
nothing nothing to gain from going out
there yeah
you got a wreck it's a big thing with
guys i'm a man but
it's not always good it's not manly it's
almost like
see what you did yeah right right
this is a weird wreck i'm going out
outside the gate here but
uh i was in uh texas
this weekend doing gigs and san antonio
san antonio
killer great did some rock clubs my
first like rock club tour and it was
like it was different for you so it was
like kind of a risk
kind of a risk and it went well they
they pay
better it's weird they pay better if you
sell it out if you don't sell out you're
[ __ ]
but they if you sell it out it's better
than the club did you sell it out we
sold out of some of them
so i think it worked out but uh either
way we saw great cities
san antonio great city great people they
party
uh and they have some of the best
mexican food you'll ever eat amazing
mexican food yeah good people
uh the river center's pretty i i loved
it uh but
me and my my guy i use this guy andrew
youngblood on the road he has secret
group he's that guy
oh yeah great comic great dude great
hang
on um we got really
shit-housed one night we both couldn't
stop doing
shots of tequila we went out to an after
party after the bar i mean it just got
ugly
either way we had this big plan to float
the river that's the big thing instead
you float the river on a tube and have a
couple of
high lifes i've never done this i've
i've walked the board
the is it the boardwalk the river the
riverwalk sorry i've walked it so many
times
yeah well this is like it's 30 minutes
outside but he's like it's so fun it's a
beautiful day
let's get our skivvies on and and just
get some sun and
and chill out and beat this hangover in
the sun i said great
he's like well we got to go early all
right we'll meet at 11 whatever
i'm so hungover i wake up at one you
know i missed the day
and i was like i can't move man like i'm
i'm 37 years old i can't wait to
do shows like this exactly so he's like
well this is bad he's like i'm hungover
too but he's like you're
incapacitated i was swollen and just it
was bad
i never ate and all that so he goes i
got an idea but it's going to be
expensive
and i said uh-oh did you do the the iv
we did the iv
how much did you drop on this ah well
that's the other thing when you're
hungover money is no object
because you're just like it's 250. ah i
nailed it you nailed it and then
he he was my opener and i'm the
headliner so i'm like
ah get one for him too so now we're
laying in my hotel room and we got these
two ivs and this nice older lady is just
like uh putting this in she's like oh
i do this [ __ ] all day long with you
[ __ ] finance pros i'm like we're not
finance bros we're [ __ ] we're artists
yeah we're artists god damn it they do
that all the all the bros do that on
billions
yes yes and chappelle does it on tours
oh does he yeah i mean
the funny thing is like your body it's
like you're getting that hung over your
body is telling you you gotta chill
so it's really just it's not healthy no
no i was like
my neck's always that and i just [ __ ]
pound muscle relaxers and i have people
tell me like yeah that's a [ __ ]
band-aid over a wound you're [ __ ] not
exactly
yeah so but boy i mean it works and you
drank again the next night
of with that night we drank again and we
called the lady too and she was so nice
i got her number and she was like i was
like is it okay
she's like actually yeah you're
healthier than ever like you're you're
better off than you were
the first night damn so we we did it all
over again but uh
man that [ __ ] it hurts like hell going
in
but yeah boy right when it comes in
you're like oh my god i'm superman you
can feel it going through your body and
whooshing through you
it's worth it i got the 275 package
oh what's in there she goes this 250
which is the regular that's what i got
for andrew
but she's like you're in such bad shape
the two the extra 25
gets you going quicker like it doesn't
have to process through you it just
shoots right in i said give it to me
give me the vip like viagra but for your
whole body
yes exactly so jesus it for me it just
leveled me out and killed the hangover
andrew he was like
the rock you know so damn it was awesome
but don't make a habit of it no no for
sure that i mean it happened one year
mother's day i collapsed
the dinner table i was so hungover and
they had to take me to the er and i uh
what yeah and and i and i got the iv and
i was like i'm [ __ ] rocking yeah wow
great mother's day gift oh she was
she was devastated how old were you
sorry mom
19. oh man still in the teens
yeah it wasn't good oh boy maybe 20 i
don't know i'm impressed she made it to
the dinner
she was not happy yeah that's uh
those iv drips are a game changer but
yeah you're right they're [ __ ] not
healthy
not healthy i mean you can't [ __ ] with
nature nate you're right do you have a
hangover for a reason
but boy every now and then if you're in
a pinch because we had two shows that
night
and uh no you i mean that's you're
saving the shows
exactly and the sh i did an instagram
live of me doing the iv and everything
and so people saw it they got a little
like some buzz going
that's so good it went on reddit and all
that [ __ ] and then the shows sold out
and i went out there and i was like kind
of woozy and they were like
it was like my flu game i said the three
jokes
twice you know uh you know my order but
the third time they hit again the second
time like what the [ __ ]
i'm like what the [ __ ] exactly exactly
and we brought the iv lady we got her
free tickets and she came out with her
daughter
yeah it was really cool oh my god yeah
so it was a wild weekend but
uh actually it works if you're sick too
i think if you have like a really bad
cold
i believe it um that's [ __ ] amazing
yeah it's just vitamins and all these
electrolytes like going right in you
there's no
there's no middle man damn
good what a wreck a great room one of
the best you you were kind of
you know a little skeptical going into
this rag you're like is he gonna be on
board
well it's so un it's so unrelatable but
it's a [ __ ] rex or
you know let's be broad with our ex yes
it's a hell of a wreck
going broad and that's a toast too to
the iv lady toast to andrew for thinking
of it
uh but he was like the show must go on
the show isn't it what a name too young
like i know if your last name is young
blood no one's calling you andrew
yeah that's a [ __ ] cool name young
just a yo young one that's a cool name
jewish guy you'd think he was a native
american or something but it's jewish
i know also also a good name for
adrenochrome
yeah youngblood you know that's what
like you know these uh
these crazy epsteins are drinking young
blood
is that what it's called adrenochrome
did i get that right
i have no idea what you're talking about
oh that's the q anon thing adrenochrome
they say these elites drink
right right kid's blood yeah it's crazy
it's all crazy but you just [ __ ] joke
about it
jesus christ yeah but this iv stuff it's
just funny that humans
are so advanced that we're like we will
find a way to keep getting [ __ ] up
and invent things like this iv
apparently like doctors do
it finance guys do it yeah i know i knew
a friend
i think a friend of a friend who's a
doctor and he's like i do it to myself
all the time he's like i'm thinking of
starting a side business of it and i was
like
oh yeah i mean yeah i mean people would
when you're hungover you're like
you say i will do anything to stop this
oh so what's 250 bucks if you got that
to burn burn it
think how many times have i spent money
tons of unnecessary money on uh take out
or like
to food delivery because i'm like i'm so
hung over here here's 80
for a burger and some fries and then you
get like eight diet cokes and two
gatorades
you know you get it all sent to your
house because you're so hungover but
money is no object because you're in
pain i'll tell you what speaking of
takeout bumps me out i ordered pizza
from
like a very reputable pizza place last
night
[ __ ] delivery the flavors were good
the pie was soggy as [ __ ] i
cannot stand a soggy delivery pie man
i'm a new yorker it hurts my
soul i'm with you and they feel like
they got you because you're like it's
here
i guess i gotta take it what am i gonna
send it back it's
tough because uh
there's a place i really like they do
weird slices it's called pizza
collective
all right it's a new york city spa i'm
gonna shout it out they do a carbonara
slice
they do a casio a pepe slice they do
weird ass slices
but i don't think it's a gimmick i think
the pizza is actually pretty good
and uh part of town i don't know it's
like 72nd i think
oh it's good it's really good uh
there you go yeah how's the how are the
ratings there am i crazy got five stars
or 4.5
that's pretty good pretty good yeah no i
i think it's real
solid closes at 10 though what the
hell's that that killed me last night
they [ __ ] me last night everything's
closing early man we may as well live in
yeah look at those
they're slices they're crazy creative
which i love and look at that dough that
bun
or the bread is so fluffy and flaky
they're crunchy slices i want a crunchy
slice
what's with these soggy [ __ ] slices
interesting i'm i'm
see i got to push but i like i don't
like the thick i like a thin
crust uh what is the thick crunch sick
i can't speak anymore what if the thick
crust is uh
is still crispy though all right i'll
give you that i'll give you that
it's crispy yeah that does that it but
they all look like grandma slices like
they're great their grandma
the uh the sicilian they're all sicilian
to me that's a lot of bread
i want the cheese i want the sauce i
want the topping
dude these look pretty great i don't
know it's almost like a croissant
pizza you're gonna like it remember
bagel bites
pizza on a bagel we can eat pizza
any time never got into them i mean i i
definitely had friends who had them in
the freezer but i never i never
i seen that bag in the freezer was like
oh but i love pizza and i love bagels in
new york those are like our two things
so like i was just like
i'm not i'm not wowed it feels like uh
like a hacky if a guy was i'm half jew
half italian
i'm a bagel bite comedian
that's what it was yeah it killed but
there were there were people in the back
going
yeah we were unimpressed the snobs in
the background impressed i mean
when i was a kid h is before h h closed
i mean my dad would go running and come
back with h bagels that was like our
sunday morning tradition
and it's like you're just having the big
freshest bagels on the planet
h yeah what happened why did they go
under they were the number one
i have no idea i have no idea what
happened
and then what what is the ultimate
because i don't i'm not a bagel guy what
is the ultimate bagel in new york i
think there's a few great spots
uh i like essa bagel i've heard of essa
i like
uh oh sns i like i love barn you can't
go wrong with barney greengrass
it's a great spot that's the jew mecca
russ and daughters
very legit oh yeah okay uh man there's a
few places in brooklyn i liked i mean
[ __ ] i used to always go to the uh bagel
smith in williamsburg they're pretty
solid
so you can tell a good bagel like if i
it's not like i have a [ __ ] gift it's
it's you know they're
they're well made they're fresh because
they're people who are like i'll never
i'll never get a bagel on toast and
you're like well you've never had a good
bagel
interesting if it's fresh out of the
oven you don't need to get it toasted
okay i'm learning i see
it's too much i would i scoop it we
could scoop it that's good
there's nothing against scooping a bagel
but it's too much but i'm just saying
uh do you do do you do what do you put
on it
i like glocks and sour cream sour cream
i mean uh cream cheese oh okay okay
i was like what the [ __ ] i almost got
stabbed here with a menorah
that was terrifying the mexican bagel
um yeah man i [ __ ] i love a good
bagel can i yeah yeah
it's all it's all bread let's be honest
it's just you're eating bread
yeah but you gotta go everything so what
is a holla chala is like a
it's like a puffy bread i don't know the
ingredients but
it rises ah it's like a it's like a
really it's like a cloud
oh i don't know the holla you know pull
up a picture of the collar i hear about
a holla they always say that on the uh
give of hollow french toast
no it's [ __ ] amazing oh that looks
like a marble rye
oh that's good yeah i know it's really
good that's great bro
very eggy it's really good all right all
right i'm into it yeah that's great
bread
oh it's oh dude you get a little if they
if they
i don't like people that are married to
just the plain color like look what
they're doing here they're making it
like almost looks like like a pretzel
hollow right yeah and you get cheese
get innovative baby oh yeah live a
little i got a weird wreck for you
please and this is strictly for
travelers
because we're travelers man we're on the
road every week this
has made i [ __ ] hate hotel soap it
makes me crazy
i bring my own bar of soap i got a
little travel case i like i don't like
body wash i like a [ __ ] ball
i hate bodyweight i'm a bar man i'm with
you and
yeah i bring like i just i was on the
road i bought a bar
and i was like why don't i do this every
week you get that shitty hotel bar
you can't even get it to foam it's like
you're trying to make [ __ ] fire
with your hands yes it's it's stiff
and it doesn't lather no lag it's like
putting a like a bathroom tile against
your skin it's and you get nothing out
of it
awful and i'll check my pits after i use
it and they still stink they stink so
what am i doing here
it's i can't i i'm so depressed
just having a [ __ ] bar in the shower
you're like why don't i do this every
week
bought the little travel case for the
soap makes such a difference doesn't
that get a little slimy though with the
residue and the wetness
and the lather in there i don't know i
got the case
i know but i feel like the case gets all
gooey and it hasn't gotten gooey at all
all right
i don't want it to get gooey i used to
keep it in a ziploc i used to do the
same thing the ziplock
yeah that'll get that'll get gross yeah
it got gross you got to get a case
okay give me a case link if you got one
oh
they sell them at [ __ ] walgreens case
link i don't know
i thought i'm picking like a cool glass
cigar look at that thing
could call amazon get it for three
dollars
a case link you can't [ __ ] google
case i like the idea of like the old
guys in the 30s at the cigarette case
and you're like
soap cakes it's like a brass sexy
little case that flips open well dude
the cigarette cases look badass
oh yeah you guys if you had not just a
cigarette case but like the personal
like that was the whole
that was the whole thing you had a gold
cigarette case you're like this
motherfucker's rich
oh yeah i even like those old cop flip
wallets you know they would flip the
badge down oh badass i love a flip i
stole a fireman's badge once yeah my
family went on vacation to florida and i
got drunk
and i found a fireman's badge and a cab
and i stole it and i was like this will
be funny to just like whip out of my
friends
and my mom and dad found it i was like
getting way too drunk all the time
and i was high as [ __ ] one day and they
found it and they gave me an
intervention
and my mom flashed the badge at me oh
that's great it was brutal she's like
you have a problem she's like what is
this
and i was high i should like i was gonna
mail it back
oh you were never gonna be how would i
have mailed it back
i had nothing she got you there i had
nothing
and it's like you're trying every angle
as a kid you're like
i i don't know my mom would find
cigarettes or weed i would just be like
it's because of you
and i'd run out because i was like i
didn't have anything else
right right you hurt me i'm traumatized
you're bad parents i'm calling social
services they're like shut up
literally give me an intervention
because over [ __ ] weed and a
fireman's
badge that's hilarious can you imagine
them finding a fireman's badge they're
just like what the [ __ ]
you had uh it's not what is that called
contraband
like you have weed and you have like cop
stuff that's
yeah that's illegal like my mom finds
that she's like he's living a double
life
and it's like so dumb it's a fireman's
badge like you can do [ __ ] with a cop
badge right you can impress
what can you do with a fireman's badge
you just hold up they're like there's a
fire go over there
i'm coming to this bar i'm checking your
meter
yeah that's true but i mean it could
work at a bar with a lady like oh i got
to get back to the the station well what
do you do
let's flip that bad so the panties are
dropping like you're the least jacked
fireman i've ever seen in my life
i'm like they need one of us yes i take
care of the dalmatian
that's my thing i get the cat out of the
tree
our friend rachel feinstein had a friend
no she had an ex-boyfriend
who just uh faked a limp
and claimed he was in the iraq war what
and he wasn't he was like i was in the
war i uh
yeah and he just wasn't and she and she
was just like
you just lied about being in the war and
having a limp and he was like yeah
wow man so that's worse than me just
having a fireman's back wayward at least
you have something
you know tangible this guy's going off a
fake limp
oh my god this guy's a sociopath that's
commitment though
commitment the weird though thing is
when he's like [ __ ] the chick and he
walks to the bathroom she's like hey
what was that no limp there he's like oh
it comes and goes guys are so safe yeah
yeah the mug drops
in slow motion she's like wait a second
oh man
isn't that sad i was thinking about this
in the shower today because oh we go
back to movies every 10 seconds
we're movie buffs they were such a big
part of our lives and i don't feel like
that's the case anymore now it's
uh some kid's quoting like a tick tock
or something and like i'm the old boomer
queef but
but they're always there you can always
go back to them if you want to like
movies
they they're always there of course
they're there but they're so long and i
feel like people now
young people don't can't handle that
whole arc of a two hour or an hour and a
half
film i'll say this i was i was with the
lady last night and we're watching heat
speaking of long
it's a three-hour movie but so good it's
good
it's a good one she's so long she could
not get into it i'm not gonna do it it's
amazing she there's some she has
something against robert de niro
what and like she she it took her
[ __ ] forever to warm up to midnight
run
it took her she's a little younger it
took her
she couldn't do casino because she's
seen good fellows in the irish ah yeah
so she's like it's just the same movie
i'm like it is but you don't understand
yeah i'm trying to defend scorsese
and it's a true story yeah in defense of
the movie
but it is tough i understand if you're
like it's already not your genre and
you're like
you know tommy dd so you know it's like
the same
tone of every movie yeah exactly but uh
the music and the motown and like
yeah the suits and the car i get it but
and my girl's the same way it's like she
just can't get into it and then i go
you know this director uh diddled uh a
kid i'm talking about polanski she's
like
he did now she's googling that she's
like now this is a movie i'm like
what are you kidding this guy's a genius
come on you're killing me
i turned around to chinatown which is
like i think
top one of the top movies of all time oh
forget about it forget about a girl on
chinatown she loved it but
she was like that's she could not
believe it how dark the ending was
yeah and i was like yeah you used to be
able to make a hit with that
right right people weren't it's not
people i think people would still
embrace it i think it's
[ __ ] studios man i think they're
cowards and they won't make a dark movie
anymore like
a lot of them do bomb i guess though too
like
a lot of them do bomb but chinatown was
best picture i think
was it yeah it's incredible it's
incredible i just thought of a great
sitcom for you and and your gal yeah
this is this is such a relatable premise
it's
the older guy i'm not saying older but
like
you're older than her seven years on her
yeah same with mine exactly the same
seven years the attention span versus
the movie
i mean just you trying to show her [ __ ]
and her being like this is boring and i
don't get it and he's a predator so i
can't support him and you're like i know
but it's genius work
i mean this is a fascinating she can
look past dichotomy
i mean we were watching la confidential
and she was like i wish we had spacey
back and i'm like thank you all right
like i'm not saying like i'm not saying
what he did is okay
yeah but i'm saying yeah i miss him a
little bit
can we admit that we missed the work a
little bit of course he's in a ton of
great pictures
also he's a talent you ever seen him on
a james lipton show he does like 20
different impressions he does pacino he
does de niro they're all killer
oh he's great all the hard ones yeah
yeah good point just walking too
[ __ ] such hack but yeah no no he i
love i loved him
on left and he was great and he's like
you know i heard he's a real [ __ ]
but
uh he is great yeah it is hilarious that
he plays
bobby darren like literally 14 years
he's like 14 years older than bobby
darren was when he died and he's playing
like young bobby daddy
and you're like this is a [ __ ] dude
that needs to be checked a little bit a
little bit of a stretch you need you
need a friend who's like
you're old right you're playing a teen
idol and you're [ __ ]
50. yeah yeah and he's still good in the
movie like yeah he's great
because he can sing and he can dance and
you're like and then you see what bobby
darren looked like and you're like it is
[ __ ] up that he kind of looks like him
yes but he's just old
he's old yeah but man gays are so
talented it's insane
yeah what is that i was talking to alex
english last night funny comic
i love alex yeah great guy and we had
this guy
big pistons fan is that right huge he
was at the [ __ ] malice of the palace
oh wow the big fight wherever with the
family were fighting the fans
he was a kid yeah he's a detroit guy big
detroit i don't even know that
well he he's a cool cat and uh we were
just talking about he's like
isn't it weird that there are unfunny
gay comics i'm like he has a couple
unfunny gay comments like i know
who's funnier than gays like just the
trauma we go we have to come out to our
parents
and he's black so he's like and i'm in
like the black thing and we're black
people are very religious so now you got
that aspect so like
we got to figure out how to make light
out of all this [ __ ] and i'm like that
is a great point i never thought about
that
yeah and it's so true but like that's
why gay guys are so
into art and like theater and all this
[ __ ] because they
that it's an escape and they want to
express and they go out and they sing
and they dance and uh
and they do comedy and he's like so it's
weird when i meet a unfunny gay comic
because
it's like are you kidding you've been
through so much you can't be funny yeah
but just going through
tragedy doesn't make you talented
although
i think with gays being talented in the
arts at least it's like a lot of them
rebel from you're more accepted in the
arts than you are in sports
right so just you could be a talented
gay athlete i mean
but one of the first i think it's one of
the first nfl players for the raiders
just came out as gay that's how rare it
is and the arts you're embraced
so i mean you're and you're celebrated
so it's like do you want to be
celebrated in spite of being who you are
in sports or do you want to be
celebrated because of who you are in the
arts
yeah good point good point what's the we
had michael sam
but he was a college player when he came
out i believe oh and then yeah i think
he played for the rams for like a minute
but he didn't last long
a couple of gay basketball players john
amichi was a gay
player uh then there's uh
one of the collins brothers is gay i
think too uh i think jaron
playing for the rams though that's a
tough name for a gay player
you gotta ram it up uh yeah you know is
it jason
yeah they were twins what both gay i
don't think so thank god they weren't
connected i know right i got to watch
you do this gay [ __ ]
yeah what do you call that siamese yeah
is that racist conjoined is that the
join there you go yeah yeah i wonder how
siamese got tied into that i don't know
what about these cats yeah this guy just
came out yeah carl massive
first openly active player i mean there
was a show back in the day on espn
called playmakers
and there was a gay player and he was
the tight end unsurprisingly
not really using your imagination here
uh writing staff yeah well at least it
wasn't a wide receiver
and then there's uh [ __ ] the they
were trying to do every taboo so there's
a running back who's like
been weathered and be and he like hit
his girlfriend
and they were like and he was like
you're expecting me to be violent on the
field and not bring that back home and
we're like
yes that's actually exactly what we're
expecting right you to be violent in
your sport
and not beat up a woman yes yes exactly
exactly that is tough though cause
we we can still be funny at all you know
we can go back
but it's different of course i mean i
was talking to a
to a porn star in the front of my show
in tampa the last year
great by the way tampa is the best i
love performing oh yeah how was that we
didn't even get it incredible i sent you
a video of me with bobby jewell do you
see that oh yeah
i didn't know who it was for a second
but then i got it bobby jewel the
legendary uh owner of tampa but
i did end up going out with him no he
came to the club
we hung but he uh yeah he had a few in
him yeah he uh
brought us all pizza he used to run the
club and he he would get sauced he was a
lot of fun
legend legendary guy would give you a
ton of [ __ ] you know what i like about
you morel
you're old school i'm like i think i'm
just a regular guy he'd be like you
could take a beat and i'm like i don't
want to take it
pick me up hammered in his uh mercedes
convertible
singing jersey boys you're just driving
big girls
they don't cry all right
catches a little wind you're like all
right bobby i want to put that top up
yeah yeah great guy funny guy old
old-fashioned
just crooner drunk womanizer like
everything every time he has a breakup
i'm like i'm like well it sounds like
you really finally met the girl
uh that you know it's good for you and
he'll be like oh please
she dumped me this morning and i would
have left her ass in the dirt if it
didn't happen myself
never has a moment where you're like you
okay he's like please
yeah yeah like therapy would not
penetrate bobby no
no no he he's like what's the guy kid
stays in the picture
what's that guys oh robert evans he's
robert evans like a scummy version of
robert evans like if robert
florida robert yeah florida robert evans
if robert evans would
own the strip club it would be bob
robert evans ruled met chinatown
there you go godfather rosemary's baby
they're making a movie i think
with oscar isaac and jake gyllenhaal and
it's one of them's copeland the other
one's robert evans it's behind the
it's the making of the godfather it
could be really cool oh man i love that
[ __ ] i'm all in
and uh yeah bobby we had so much fun man
great great to be there
great crowds i'm talking to this porn
star on the front row and i was like is
it does it ruin sex for you you know
wait wait wait wait wait what what the
porn star on the porn star hold on i was
in tampa
oh okay i mean still hold on no that's
how i got into this
okay okay i missed that part well i'm
talking i was like is it
does it ruin real sex for you because
you get paid for it ah yes
yes and then uh i was like you know
sometimes someone off the stage tells me
to tell him a joke and i'm like you know
i get paid for this
yeah so i'm like is that you know she's
like no i still it's like it's
i i'm better at real sex because it
means more to me
but i was just fascinated by that you
know i think it makes complete sense
like
one time i was just years ago but i was
hanging out with a porn star in florida
as you do and i was like why isn't why
am i not being blown yet
why is my dick still dry we've been
talking for 10 minutes what's going on
and i realized like oh yeah that's her
job and blah blah blah
and it's the same with like these people
who hang out with you you're not really
that funny off stage
yeah i just got done work like let me
have a sip i turned into one of the
people i can't stand yeah i totally did
and so i feel bad and i was wrong and
all that but like
she's gotta she still has to like you to
[ __ ] you
i guess but but my point is
we're funny on stage but when we're
together or it's me you and mackie or me
you and veda or me you enlist
the we're laughing but we're comfortable
we know each other
it's different so you think she gets
together with a few porn stars she's
like doing just like [ __ ] the
bathroom i think so
yeah i'd imagine you do feel weird that
they don't just like shake your hand and
be like
do you want to go to a blue broom closet
like right now and you're like you're
like oh i can't i can't
i know i think that all the time but and
plus they're just oozing sex like their
tits are out
they got fake hair and like you know
tattoos
we're not losing comedy i'm just in a
shirt yeah i guess that's a good point
that's a good point
maybe we are losing a little cop are we
using a little a little yeah yeah you
know see look at like matt's like yeah
you're oozing
you want to ooze a little just a hint of
a news yeah
yeah then that where the women find
funny men sexy you're like
really jerry lewis jim carrey jim carrey
i think i mean look at the tale he
pulled in
lauren holly yeah i guess she's she was
high jenny mccarthy
he had a little those have got to be
some rough conversations she's like
you're anti-vaxx right and he's like
sure hold on let me
yeah yeah i got the vaccine right here
yeah yeah
uh yeah that's true i get i just it just
seems like such a
it's the opposite like at least porn
star is
equal sex funny equals goofy wacky silly
to me it's like
pie in the face slipping on a banana
peel
that doesn't equal sex to me but i think
it it is like
people want to laugh man you want a guy
who's just brooding all the time
i don't know that guy to me is kind of
hot yeah that's kind of hot he's like a
like a robert mitchum paul newman kind
of stoic
quiet guy paul newman was hot dude oh
man that was a hot man
hot hot guys but he also was hot because
he would
like all right i'm gonna defend comedy
for a second he was hot because he would
play pathetic characters too
he was a hot like in the verdict paul
newman's a [ __ ] drunk loser
yeah good point and he's and like that's
to me is my favorite role
of any movie he did really i think it's
his
i don't know if it's his best movie it's
probably my favorite paul newman movie
yeah because it's just so i mean [ __ ]
great movie man
great and uh yeah i think the fact that
he could go to that place
yeah like anything like i don't know
don't you think
you get your prop like charlie theron
got her oscar by going ugly
going ugly interesting yeah and in the
movie cool hand luke
paul newman that's a great movie yeah
that might be his best
of course but he gets into a fist fight
with this guy
and loses but you like him for it
because he the guy was way bigger
and he he never stopped and he wouldn't
go down yeah and the big guy was like i
gotta this is like
a bummer i can't keep watching this guy
just keep cut getting up and getting
knocked out and he's out like he looks
like jesus when he's on yes
after all the eggs remember a lot of
religious uh undertones there
that's a [ __ ] cool movie great movie
best picture
uh also a great movie but yeah paul
newman and if you watch clips of him and
his wife
what's his wife's name i forgot she's
really really cool though
cool lady second wife by the way oh yeah
uh
that was the real one i feel like the
second wife is the one that really
connected but
he she busts his balls the whole every
interview she's like busting his balls
and he can take it and he's laughing
and he never hits her back and uh
well he never like shits on her back
woodward joanne woodward yeah yeah and
it's a great it's just great watching
them together
because yeah yeah she's she seems like a
fun lady that's uh joanne woodward
they had a good thing yeah that's the
famous line why go out for uh for a
burger when you get a steak at home
there you go well i i don't love that
quote because
sometimes you want a burger for sure i
get it yeah but you're only gonna eat
steaks for the rest of your life
yeah exactly i think i think it's less
the quality of the meat and more just
the variety
in your life yeah yeah exactly why you
go out for a [ __ ]
uh you know wild turkey when you got a
[ __ ] 18 year old scotch at home
i don't know sometimes you want a shot i
guess i can't explain human nature to
you
if you're breaking it down by drinks and
food
but women hear that and they're like ah
yeah yeah it'd be nice but it's also a
fairy tale all right what do you got for
a bit we got we
got a couple ideas here i i got problem
is i got a few that are hitting so
they're not worth really bringing it oh
yeah give me give me something
something that's not hitting okay under
construction something here i have this
idea like
so a guy talking about aliens after the
show so i'm thinking about aliens so
what my idea is like what if aliens come
here and we treat them great
like how much would that piss off
mexicans
you know what i mean like like
especially if we continue to call the
mexicans illegal aliens
right and we just call the aliens aliens
yeah that's great
surely this has been done i feel like
someone must have this bit well
i think i might have heard the aliens
thing but just
the mexicans the mexican versus actual
aliens is a great premise and we treat
them great
have you heard this then we're gonna if
we treat them
if they're smart we gotta treat like you
know there's gonna be rednecks like we
gotta build a ceiling
yeah that i've never heard something
like okay that's great
like these aliens don't even speak the
language then the aliens are like we do
we also speak
mandarin and they're like [ __ ] we gotta
stop these aliens you know
yeah they're taking our jobs right oh
that's great
there's something there i love it i love
it that's a great bit
speak the language the wall i'm trying
to think of other uh
maybe we could go to the alien planet
like we go to cancun
oh that's [ __ ] great you know like
and the alien's like jesus christ then
we got a starbucks and a tv
fridays and senior frogs on uh whatever
mars we're just like we're just [ __ ]
in a jacuzzi and they're like these
[ __ ] they p
these people just come here to vacation
we're struggling
yeah then you gotta pay off the alien
federalists like oh sorry
i hit that stripper or whatever it is
it's also something funny about how we
always like we think aliens coming here
is going to be great but like you look
at every alien movie you look at like
every every group that's come in big
numbers to another place
it has usually been violent yeah yeah
that's kind of just human nature yeah
and then we're like we're like oh let's
find some aliens you're like this could
go [ __ ] bad
right yeah so true i mean the irish came
that was ugly the italians came that was
ugly yeah the jews it happens every
every week
we came that was ugly yes americans
native americans didn't
appreciate it another thing with the
alien like what if we go there and we
try to drink
bring drugs back and we got to go
through the border like the uh
you know the space border and they're
like whoa whoa whoa you got a ton of
drugs here and you're like i know but i
was doing them up there they're legal
there
like they're legal on mars yeah we go
there to get [ __ ] up we go like
i got my fake tits on mars they did a
horrible job you know
that's a lot here this is great there's
something here all right i love it i
love like an idea of a low rider
spaceship
all right what do you got i'm getting
too into it all right this is uh
this is not as good as that i feel like
that's a thick chunky bit you got there
this is uh i just trying to work on this
whole thing about how
it sucks that what women find attractive
about men
is like kind of nice and fun and
wholesome
like i like a smart man like a funny man
like ambition
but what everything men like about women
just biologically
is creepy you know it's like tits and
ass and all this [ __ ]
and uh women
like arms my girlfriend's like oh i love
a man with good arms and all this [ __ ]
i saw you doing pull-ups outside the
studio yeah exactly
so first of all every now and then a guy
will go sleeveless
so you're like well that's just free
porn
and two when a woman likes a guy she'll
touch his arm
that's always how you know a girl a girl
likes you she'll touch the arm you're
like
so you get to touch the thing you're
attracted to i like tits
like how [ __ ] am i like all the things
that men like about women are like
private parts
or or you know what's the word uh
inappropriate interesting but the arm
you like women like arms she's like oh i
love a good
good arm veiny arms muscular arms fit
arms
you gotta arm all day long but uh
you know i like uh you like a butt or
whatever you can't
can't focus on the butt yeah you can't
uh you can't be consoling a woman by
grabbing your tits
there there yeah yeah can i buy you a
drink you know
i don't know is there anything there yes
it's like you what you like about
the thing but there are women like dick
too
i know but if you send a dick pic to a
woman she's like jesus
but you think it's an armpit yeah i
guess you can say an arm pick
i guess you could send an armpit and
it's a little weird to be like oh weird
check it out yeah but i don't know i
just like uh
like you know girls are like oh i saw
this guy at the gym he was ripped
but it's like the things you like if you
see a woman at the gym and she looks
stacked you're kind of like geez
like you're attractive yeah that's
that's true but there's something about
like
the touching the touching is interesting
i think that's something
you could you touch the arm to show you
like them
yes there's no part of you i can touch
to show i'm interested
because you already know i'm interested
aha
maybe that's it yeah just me approaching
you
yeah you have to like buy her a drink
buy a drink don't play with their hair
yeah i can't touch myself to show them
interested
oh that's great that's good that's good
i can't be like yeah yeah what do you do
for a living
yeah i don't know maybe it's two on the
nose but
uh i feel like there's something there
touching the arm
to show you're interested is interesting
because that's like direct that's like a
direct line
so direct yeah that part of the arm is
getting something you laugh
yeah women i think you may have to just
go that straight up or it's like they
touch the arm like ha ha and they touch
the other yeah you can
they can't say a joke and you're like
hahaha i can't touch what i like
when you tell a funny joke right right
you say something funny i just touch you
i'm like
something there i don't know i'm trying
to think the hair flip is good too
hair flip is interesting they they flip
their hair
every guy is taught that if a girl
touches your arm she likes you and then
the hair touching is
it means she likes you whenever i see a
girl do it when she's talking to me i'm
always like she must have like
a twitch or something she must have like
a nervous thing you know what i mean
yeah i'm like
does that make sense to you like why are
you touching your hair yeah but i
i do think that but i also know like oh
i think i got a shot here but
also when a girl touches your arm you
flex do you ever do that i have a bit
about this what was she oh really
it's different than yours but i had a
girl break up with me and she touched my
arm to console me and i flexed which was
like a real [ __ ] low point in my life
yeah like i thought that was gonna
change her mind
like she touches my arm she's like wait
a second right
i didn't know you could curl 8.5 this
changes everything
yeah yeah definitely a low point
it's a flex thing i bet women are the
same way like if you touch
a woman's stomach like all right i'll
see you later and she's like
yes yeah whatever you're insecure about
yes yes
interesting okay that's a different bit
for sure but that uh
that could tie in yeah yeah all right
i'll play with this
i'll noodle oh yeah all right hey let's
plug some dates man oh
subscribe to our patreon uh patreon.com
we might be drunk pod
we're dropping gems we're gonna make a
nicer studio here we're loving working
here at gotham studio thank you matt
this has been killer
uh throw some live dates mark and you
saw the you saw the whiskey
tasting so uh folks it's coming it's
coming baby and you're all a part of it
and we're gonna get a label
and a distributor and we we already the
the wheels are in motion
we're drunk driving uh hot dates i don't
know when this comes out so i'll go real
future
uh let's see toledo funny bone
houston improv philly helium that'll
sell out
love philly philly rules man buffalo
helium
dayton funny bone appleton wisconsin at
skyline
arlington improv brea improv albany
west palm beach comedy connection in
providence madison company on state
all over the road what do you got there
sloppy jalopy
madison comedy on state the 8th through
10th uh
the 15th through 17th i got oklahoma
city the 23rd through 25th nashville
tennessee might we might add a show
there so stay tuned
we got uh moved governors and levittown
to belmore so the brokers removed it
uh but that's gonna be killer the 30th
through the 31st of july first weekend
of august i'm in lexington kentucky
then we i'm uh we got uh comedy club of
kansas
missouri august as well portland helium
the 19th to 21st of august and we got
the last weekend of august
royal michigan one of my favorites
boston philly
samurai.com shows
can't wait can't wait to be keep hitting
the road i'm loving it man
yeah the road is back the crowds are
coming out people are talking there's a
buzz about the pod it's only going to
grow from here we got our own whiskey
we'll get some merch cooking
and check out our specials we're on
youtube give us a like a number
a comment be positive for the love of
god and uh yeah
thanks again keep drinking we might be
drunk
we might be drunk as long as we are
hanging out you know we might be drunk
raise a glass
let's talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a
bit
maybe drunk we might be
drunk yeah